hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i wanted to talk about
the right to buy scheme
[Music]
so the right to buy scheme is if you are
a tenant that's living in a council
house or a government-owned house or a
housing association and you've lived
there a long time then you may be
eligible to buy the house at a discount
and a lot of people have said to me you
know samuel i'm in a house and the
council have told me that i've got a
right to buy it with a discount
is this good is this another one of
those government schemes where there's
loads of catches and i should be really
careful you know what are your thoughts
so i'm going to give you the pros and
i'm going to give you the cons and then
i'm going to give you my opinion of my
thoughts on the right to buy scheme
so firstly what it is exactly uh this
was introduced in 1980 by margaret
thatcher so she brought it in it was
scrapped in 2016 in scotland it was
scrapped last year 2019 in wales it's
been capped in northern ireland so it's
not quite the same in england it is
still a thing so here's what it is
literally i think you live there three
years
and you get a 35
discount off of an apartment that you
really applies to houses too they just
get slightly less the longer you've
lived there the more of a discount that
you get so people are coming to me and
they're saying like someone got 50
percent i got 60
i can get discounted with this house
so i've locked into it and
normally with these things there's a lot
of cons you know you if you do it then
you've got this and this and this and
this now listen if you buy a house
discounted by the council you can't then
immediately sell the house so you've got
to wait you've got to wait five years
before you can sell it and get 100 of
the profit from it and there's a sliding
scale but if you buy it at 35 discount
and then immediately sell it that
discount you will have to give back but
after five years you can sell it
renting wise
surprisingly
you actually can
buy it and then you can immediately rent
the house out as long as you've got the
correct kind of mortgage you can buy it
discounted from the council and then
rent it out which is really weird
because usually the government are empty
you being an investor they want you to
buy somewhere and live there forever
so in terms of cons
i don't really think there's that many
cons
of course you need to raise the money
and you need to buy it and it might not
be the best property in the world
but generally speaking my advice is
this scheme
is pretty good it's pretty good and i
personally have got friends i know
people in fact even some of the people
we've had on winners wednesday like nsa
and genevieve mother and daughter um
patricia bright she's been on my channel
her mom
a lot of people that i that i know or i
know of have bought properties with the
right to buy and have made a lot of
money off of it and i've been really
really successful
so
i don't think there's that many cons i
think it's amazing i think if you're in
a house and you have the opportunity to
buy it at a big discount i would just
say go ahead and buy it find the money
go ahead and buy it it's not every day
that you come across a property
like 40 50
below market value that's incredible
just because you've lived there a few
years i mean geez i'm even considering
moving into some council houses and
staying there for a few years just for
the discounts like i'm kind of kidding
but
it's seriously good um
they've scrapped it in a lot of
countries in a lot of places and i
suspect they're going to scrap it in
england soon at some point as well so if
you have the opportunity to buy it i
would say go ahead and buy it
also the government are pretty angry
about this i've seen articles where
they're going nuts because
they said i'll read this so it was said
the damning figures
the damning figures
also show that more than 40 percent of
london council homes bought under the
government's right to buy program are
now rented out privately so they're not
happy they're like the damning figures
they don't want you to buy and rent out
personally i think
good for the people that bought it and
rented out if you've managed to get the
money together and buy it then good for
you and go ahead and rent it out i think
it's great so
my thoughts are do it do it do it
i wouldn't be surprised if the
government scrapped the rent to buy soon
and introduce lots of other schemes
which are
riddled with more strings attached than
this one so that's my thoughts if you've
bought a house on the right to buy
scheme
let me know i want to know what discount
you got okay not not in percentages but
in actual cash how much because you you
actually make money when you buy a house
if you buy a house for 100 grand and
it's worth 150 effectively you've kind
of made 50 000 pounds then you make
money when it goes up then you make
money when it rents out so property is
just a great way to make money and i
would take advantage of this scheme some
of the other schemes i'm not so sure of
help to buy lifetime isa i don't like
these shared ownership i don't like this
i'll put a link to a
playlist with all the schemes that i'm
not a fan of you can check out the
playlist right here also if you want to
come and learn about property and how to
really make money and be a professional
property investor come down to the
property investors crash course you can
do that right here and of course please
don't forget to subscribe if you enjoy
the videos subscribe over here turn the
notification bell on and i look forward
to seeing you next time